meanwhile we are behind scenes of
another superhero showdown
Supergirl versus the flash and also on
CBS tonight the stars of scorpion take
on a ferocious win mission always game
for a little stunt action dr. McPhee and
Elias cabal just hanging around the set
literally the co-stars and real-life
couple are harnessed and hoisted ten
feet in the air trying to hold on with a
massive tornado hits in tonight's
episode what I really want to do is like
jump and then have them lift me and then
drop me in you know I'm like a bungee
could that be fun one thing about the
harness is it's grabs hold of you in a
precarious position as a male member of
the human race right there's a low man
faster than a speeding tornado okay long
superhero but tonight the flash gets to
speedy in his old world and ends up in
super girls for big series crossover
Grant Gustin guest stars and let's just
say he's got some student I really the
first time I saw her in that suit I was
pretty envious of that
at the S I let you get here first we
were just talking with Grant and he
actually confessed that he's a little
jealous of your suit
really yeah it's yet these superheroes
belong to the same grisly Comics
universe but the crossover is a first
since both shows are on different
networks but it is the first time
Melissa Benoist and grant have crossed
paths you and Melissa both came from
Glee yeah so what's it like to being
able to share in this experience
together it's cool I mean me and Melissa
never actually had a scene together on
Glee so to actually be here on set with
her and get to do this is a lot of fun